joining us now is a very dear friend of
the show
astrologer extraordinaire elisa kelly
hi hi lisa
hi drew how are you today
i am doing very well how are you guys
thanks for having me back
oh well i mean it's like the line from
zoolander astrology it's so hot right
now
it's always been you know a very
meaningful thing
to a lot of people but i've just seen
the trends
through the roof and i was really
excited because i heard some information
and we actually texted about it but take
us through what is happening right now
well as usual there is so much going on
right now but you don't need to be an
astrologer to know that this has been
a really wild year and it totally tracks
with astrology so on
december 14th there is a solar eclipse
we are in sagittarius season right now
so things are extra extra extra
which is like perfect for holiday vibes
but
because this is a fire sign we are all
like really leaning into our passions
our philosophy we're excited about
things so
this is kind of like the perfect way to
be concluding this
pretty intense year but that's not the
only big date in december there's
another one we should be paying
attention to right
yes so there's a very big date in
december on december 21st
which is winter solstice the beginning
of capricorn season and also a
palindrome
12 21 we have the great conjunction
which is the meeting of jupiter and
saturn it only happens
every 20 years and what's more
this is going to be visible for the
first time in this intensity
for the first time in 800 years eight so
600 years
what does that mean what does it mean
newness chains
oh i mean it's it means so many things
ross i mean so many things drew
but one of them and i would say most
importantly is that they're meeting in
aquarius and this is the dawn of the age
of aquarius this time
for real are you trying to get me to
sing okay so this
is good news for people change the first
time in 800 years sagittarius into
aquarius
winter solstice this is amazing news for
people
yes just when we made it right is there
anything eliza
that we should have as a mantra this
month
well you know i think that as we move
into this
air age when we're thinking about
aquarius we're thinking about
communication
we're thinking about innovation progress
so what i'm really inviting people to do
is take time
to visualize a better tomorrow
to use this date 12 21 to think about
what does a really beautiful world in
the future look like
because everything that exists first
starts as an idea
so we collectively can do that we can
usher in this new era with beautiful
thinking beautiful imagination
and bring it to life all right 12 21 you
are my palindrome
of love remind me december 21st is a big
astrological day
thank you thank you elisa kelly